I think a really good historical
comparison for Cersei is margaret of
anjou known as the she-wolf of France
one of the strongest females in the
real-life wars the roses Margaret of
Anjou the strong Queen of England in the
1450s must exert power like a man should
have been born a man I'd rather face a
thousand swords than be shut up inside
with this flock of frightened hens she's
willing to go to any lengths politically
or otherwise to rule the country and
protect her children's rights you love
your children it's your one redeeming
quality that in your cheekbones Joffrey
is king Joffrey is king you are here to
advise him and they here to advise him
but you could also look at a load of the
other women of the wars the Roses you
know really strong women whose route to
power and whose driving motivation is
either gaining or preserving power for
their sons you're the hand of the king
no uncle clearly it would not be
appropriate for a woman to assume that
role I'm merely advising my son until he
comes of age and chooses a hand for
himself there are so many women who are
leading their sons because their
husbands are either in captured or
fleeing or in fact are just incompetent
a good King knows when to save his
strength and when to destroy his enemies
so in steps a very strong woman everyone
who isn't us
is an enemy I think that's the heart of
Cersei I think that really does draw on
what we know of real history from the
15th century there are those that say
your children were not fathered by King
Robert but they are bastards born of
incest and adultery no alive from the
lips of Stannis Baratheon I deny it
[Music]
after your atonement who says these walk
of shame designed to humiliate her I
mean it has real historical precedent
for it if we look at Jane Shore during
the reign of Richard the third she was
in a way scapegoated for a lot of the
political problems that had gone before
and she was made to walk through the
streets of London dressing her kurtal
which is more or less her under clothes
and holding a taper in front of her in
an age when women were modestly trust
and they wore veils it was actually
quite shocking to see someone dressed
like that it would have been quite
humiliating Cersei is naked when she
performs her walk of shame to us as
viewers it has almost the same impact as
seeing Jane Shore and her curdle would
have had it's almost an emotional
translation of what it would have felt
like really serious public shaming and
public penance there's a huge amount of
ritual purpose in that which is to strip
of any majesty magnificence that she
might have accrued in her career before
that point